in this video I want to talk about
titrations and ISO elite electric ph's
ISO electric ph's also known as P is and
the reason why or specifically for amino
acids the reason why is because now
we're we've talked about the structures
of all the different amino acids there
are abbreviations like that so now I
want to kind of incorporate all the
things that we talked about before
involving the henderson-hasselbalch
equation too and sort of apply it to
what we talked about with amino acids so
if you guys remember back to general
chemistry titrations were usually
acid-base neutralization reactions and
they're used for a variety of things in
in biochemistry it's helpful to look at
a titration of an amino acid to kind of
sort of understand what you know what
role the PKA the pH and all that sort of
stuff plays and how that sort of
determines what an amino acid will look
like given a certain pH so let me draw
this titration curve out so a titration
curve looks something like this where
the Y axis will be labeled as pH and the
x axis will be the amount of Oh H
equivalence if you guys remember back to
just general chemistry Oh h minus is ID
Rockside ion which is a strong base so
essentially it's its measured in in
moles of hydroxide ion right per mole of
amino acid that detail is not too
important for understanding this but it
is uh that is the unit or sort of way to
think about it essentially what we're
going to think about is we're going to
think about having an amino acid at a
very very starting at a very very low pH
for instance zero and we're going to
which is very very acidic right and
we're going to continually add the
strong base to it and that's going to
cause the the pH to rise right so when
we do that we're going to track sort of
how the the pH changes and what the
amino acid will look like at different
PHS so let me just split this up by twos
2 4 6 8 something like that
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
draw a specifically this hydration curve
we're going to use the example of
histidine so histidine if you recall is
one of the basic amino acids so we're
going to use histidine right and it's
three-letter code is H is it's one
letter code is H so we're going to draw
out histidine starting from a very very
low pH all the way up to a very very
high pH and we're going to track what it
looks like at different different points
so initially if we have histidine at a
very very very low pH right we haven't
added any o H minus equivalence we have
a very very low pH that means we have a
lot of hydra ocean hydrogen ions in the
solution so all the groups will likely
be protonated so if you recall histidine
it's a draw this out histidine looks
like this if you were going to draw
history at a very very low pH like a pH
of zero it will look like this it'll
have its Alpha carboxyl group protonated
every every group that's ionizable will
be protonated so over here we have the
amino group it'll also be protonated and
it's it's sidechain oops
fret the right the ch2 group first ch2
and then we have the emitters all group
ok with an N here and then here a double
bond here a double bond here and if it's
a
very very low pH it's going to be
protonated so we're going to track how
this amino acid will look as we add
hydroxide ion equivalents so as we add
base to a solution that contains this
amino acid what's going to happen well
these are all protonated right all these
ionizable groups this one one two and
three different ionizable groups they
all have particular pk's now that means
they're all going since they're all
protonated and they have PKS that means
they can act as acids so if something
was what we'd expect to which of these
groups would we expect to be the first
one to donate this proton
well things that are very good at doing
anything the protons are strong acids
right strong acids have low PKA s which
of these groups would we expect to be
the strongest acidic group well we know
this is a basic amino acid so it's
probably not the imidazole group it's
probably not the amino group because the
amino groups are pretty basic themselves
the middle group is not as basic as some
other groups but it's basic relative to
this carboxylic acid group that is
indeed an acid group so we would expect
that the first group should begin
donating its protons would be this
carboxylic acid group so if we imagine
this occurring you would get this
so this is an acid right here this group
here and this is its conjugate base form
so this reaction has a PKA okay and
we're gonna call this PKA one okay now
the overall charge of this thing I want
also that's another thing I wanted to
point out I want to track the charges of
these different of the amino acid as it
as the pH changes so here initially like
I said I'm having at a low pH as we add
a way to equivalence we're eventually
going to make a bunch of these now here
we have an overall charge of plus two
and the reason why is because this is a
positive charge as a positive charge and
this is a neutral charge upon this
happening upon the the carboxylic acid
group donating its proton we have an
overall charge of just plus one right
positive one positive one negative one
so how many Oh H equivalents do we need
to add to turn to turn this into this
well that's that's that's the whole idea
behind that that question sort of
requires that you answer what is in a
way to equivalent essentially if we're
adding one Oh H equivalent that means
we're going to take one oops
one acid group oops
one acid group and completely convert it
into its conjugate base form okay so
what happens is the graph looks like
this as you add the Oh H equivalents
once you've added one ohq equivalent
this is how the graph change the pH
changes like this so we have this kind
of go up like this and this is not
perfect mind you but I'm going to do my
best here okay so actually let me draw
the whole graph
something like this and then that's not
great but it's the best I can do for now
so what I want to know I want you to
notice is I want you to know these these
things called equivalence points so once
we add one whole OAH equivalent right I
want to note that this way okay so once
we've added one entire OAH equivalent we
have right here right this is the
equivalence point here something like
this okay
so like that once we've added one OAH
equivalent basically what we've done is
we started off at this point here a
let's call this point here a forgive me
if this is not all making sense just yet
but it will I promise the point a
everything that we have all the amino
acid at this very very low pH so all of
it will exist in this form but as we add
ohe equivalence we're going to the pH
will rise right and when that happens
eventually at a certain point all of the
amino acid of the histidine molecules
that are in this form right will be
converted into this form okay so add
that's specifically oh it means once
you've if you've added one equivalent of
base for this acid you've turned all
this acid into its conjugate base so at
point B here we have nothing but but
this this this uh it's a called this
form of histidine okay so if we add
another equivalent of Oh H what will we
get
well if we add another for another
equivalent of Oh H we're going to get to
front draw this H here once we add that
other equivalent the next most acidic
group it's going to donate its proton so
between the amino group in this
imidazole group we should know that the
amino group is going to have a higher
PKA so
the one with a lower PKA the middle
group will donate its proton first so
it'll look like this
the carboxyl group will remain the same
the amino group will remain the same and
then we will have the middle group
deprotonated so we'll just have that n
so now the overall charge of histidine
is zero right because it's just this
positive charge in this negative charge
here so PKA number two happened okay
that PKA belongs to the side chain this
PKA one belongs to this carboxylic acid
group okay so once we've added that
second equivalent right that second
equivalent second equivalence point is
somewhere around here okay so once we've
added that second equivalence point of
Base we reach at this new pH here
something like this okay so this point
here I'm going to call Point C Point C
here right we have all of it all the
amino acids will exist in this form so
here we have C here is what we have it
this is at point B this is at Point a
okay so now what well now this this
amino group can also donate its proton
right so let's just finish that off
really quickly it's kind of get an idea
of what histidine will look like at a
very very high pH so that's the only
protonated group left so eventually at a
high enough pH even the amino group will
act as an acid and donate its proton so
then all of the groups will be
deprotonated
oops I forgot these these ends have h's
can't believe I messed that up sorry
guys okay so there's an end there and
there that n has an H and now the
overall charge of this histidine
molecule is is negative one
okay so here's 0 here's negative 1 so
now at a high enough pH maybe you know
somewhere up here once we've added that
30 pivot right once we've added that
third equivalent essentially we've added
an equivalent for every single every
single ionizable group so there were 1 2
3 groups in their acid form that means
we must have added 3 equivalence of base
to neutralize it completely so where do
these pk's well how do these pk's these
values come into play like what how did
they what role do they play here so
there must have been a third PKA the
third pk belongs to the amino group so
if you remember back to the henderson
hasselbalch equation the pKa was equal
to the pH when the base concentration
the conjugate base concentration equaled
the the undissociated acid concentration
and essentially when we look at the
titration curve the pKa will be the half
equivalence point okay so I want to note
that here the pKa will be equal to the
half equivalence point be half
equivalence point and I'll talk about
what that means so once we've added half
an equivalent they have equivalence
point pH so that it's the pH at the half
equivalence point
so once we've added half an equivalent
right then what we have if we go if we
add half an equivalent when you go over
and find that pH that pH there will be
the pKa so what that mean
though as a half equivalent point that
means that for instance the Cystic and
think about PKA one so as we add base
we're reducing the number the number of
histidines looking in this form and then
creating more in this form so as we
approach adding a full equivalent we're
making make we're making we're losing
this and we're making more of this okay
because these these this acid group is
donating its proton so as a donations
protons it's becoming to look like this
so but notice though at the half
equivalence point what should we have
what we should have half in the acid
form and half in the base form right so
that's exactly what PKA is and just to
show to sort of prove that to you if you
recall right the henderson hasselbalch
equation was pH equals PKA plus the log
of the concentration of the conjugate
base over the acid right so if if we
have the base concentration right equal
to the acid concentration right that
means we have half of this half of the
total histidines will look like this and
half of the total histidines would look
like this
right that means this value right these
two concentrations are equal right and
if that's the case so we're taking the
log of one which is just zero so that
that basically tells us that the pKa is
basically the pH at which these two
concentrations are equal when we have
1/2 in this form and 1/2 in this form so
each PKA is just you know the next half
equivalence point
so this PKA one corresponds to the point
at which we have half of the histidine
looking like this and half of the
histidine is looking like this
this next equivalence point here all
right I don't know where that is
something like that one point five that
next half half equivalence point that pH
there is going to be our PKA two right
so and then over here somewhere
over here we got it looking like that
okay this pH is going to be our PKA
three okay so what are all these values
equal to well this PKA one is actually
the actual value is 1 point 8 2 that
means the pKa of this carboxylic acid
group right is 1 point 8 2 the pKa of
the middle group is 6.0 or so around 6
right and that makes sense right this pH
here at this at the second half
equivalence point is 6
the third PKA is nine point one seven
and that's the pKa of the amino group
right so notice that here the peak this
PKA responds to the pKa of this middle
group and then this PKA responds to the
last group that's that's you know acting
as an acid to become in base form okay
so I didn't actually know where D was so
let me let me do that here
so once we've reached that that this
point here that third equivalence point
that's where we have D right so at Point
a we only have this right at point B
right we've converted all of these into
this right we added one whole equivalent
to create it all into this then between
B and C right between B and C we have
you know this and this but as we add a
whole nother equivalent that we no
longer have B and then we just have C
hopefully this is making sense once we
have once we're at this pH if we add one
more equivalent we're going to convert
all of these into these so now I want to
go through and add a little a few more
letters so let me do that in a different
color though so at Point E oops
e F and G what's going on well at Point
E we have 1/2 in the a form and
half in the B form right
we have half in this form and half in
this form at F we have half in the B
form and half in the C form at G we have
half in the C form and half in the D
form okay so now hopefully that PKA the
P K's and then pH is and how they apply
the amino acids makes sense so you might
be expected to draw the way a particular
amino acid looks at a given pH so now
how do we find this thing called PII
what is a pie a pie a nice electric
isoelectric pH so let's kind of separate
this really quickly so an isoelectric pH
or PII is essentially the pH at which
there's an overall charge of zero right
the true definition implies there's like
it's a little bit more complex than that
oops let me let me kind of make that a
little bit more clear there's an overall
charge of zero so we want we want the
the if we want the isoelectric pH or pi
of histidine we want to know at what pH
will this form exist right well if we
want to find that all we have to do is
take the average of the pka's that are
on either side of that species right so
this species is the one that has zero
net charge right if we just take the
average of these two pka's then we'll
get the the isoelectric pH so so PKA
- so PKA - so the pi4 histidine will
equal the will equal PKA 2 plus PKA 3
/ - so our PKA - if we look back over
here was equal to 6 and our what's
called our PKA 3 was equal to 9 point 1
7 I'm just going to round things off to
make it a little bit easier and why that
over 2 so 6 plus 9 is 15 over 2 all
right so at this point I'm going to
actually approximate it right so the DPI
of histidine is approximately 7 point 5
that is the pH at which we would expect
histidine to carry no net charge overall
okay so the reason why I did histidine
here is because it's a little bit more
complex than finding the pi/4 other
amino acid because other amino acids
they normally don't have 3 ionizable
groups this one has 3 if there are only
2 ionize of root ionizable groups you
know the the carboxylic acid group and
the UM should be the Alpha carboxylic
acid group in the Alpha amino acid group
then you would just take the average of
both of those for instance uh just a
quick example I suppose a quick example
for alanine alanine the pKa of its Alpha
carboxyl group is equal to 2 point 3 4
and the pKa of its alpha amino group is
equal to nine point six nine so if we
want to find the pi/4 for L&E the pi/4
alanine is simply these two pka's added
up together divided by two so two point
three four plus nine point six nine over
two and we actually just get what do we
get I forgot the value let me actually
calculate that really quickly goodness
so we have I can't do math nine point
six nine whoops
nine point six nine plus two oh my
goodness
nine point six nine plus two point three
four divided by two we get a six point
zero to approximately so the pi/4
alanine would just be six point zero two
so that's much much easier now what you
can do for alanine is you can actually
go through and kind of think about it
this way right draw it three the three
forms that can exist in where it's where
the all groups are protonated and then
the first groups of two to give up its
proton is the carboxylic acid group then
the the the next group to give it up
would be the amino group and then you
would just take the 2pk the pKa is on
either side of the form and that that is
that has the overall charge of zero
average amount and get the P I so I hope
that was helpful
um and I'll see you next video